la actualidad más destacada del
continente africano está en France 24
Bienvenidos a África 7 días comenzamos
con los titulares en Sudán los violentos
enfrentamientos por el poder entre el
jefe del ejército a del burján y el jefe
de los paramilitares
no paran y se recrudecen en esta edición
hacemos un perfil del país que no ha
conocido la paz desde su independencia y
analizamos el trasfondo del conflicto
hablamos de cine la plataforma de
streaming Netflix y la UNESCO se han
unido para ayudar a promover las
diferentes voces de un cine africano más
espectacular les contamos más en un
momento la escritora nigeriana
estuvo en la capital colombiana Bogotá
con motivo de la Feria Internacional del
Libro aprovechamos la ocasión para
preguntarle sobre entre identidad y
poder y Nigeria
la situación en Sudán sigue
deteriorándose y el país ha entrado en
una profunda crisis explosiones ataques
aéreos y tiroteos no han cesado en la
capital jartum y otras ciudades el agua
y la electricidad están cortadas la red
telefónica dañada y los alimentos
escasean algunos países extranjeros han
conseguido evacuar a sus ciudadanos por
todas las vías solo de la Unión Europea
van más de 1500 Pero qué ocurrirá con
los huraneses según la ONU entre 10.000
y 20.000 y han cruzado a Chad mientras
que otros intentan llegar a Egipto o
Sudán del sur la intensificación de la
violencia que comenzó el 15 de abril ha
dejado más de 420 muertos y 3700 heridos
la mayoría civiles según la Organización
Mundial de la Salud
desde el comienzo de los combates los
beligerantes es decir ah del jefe del
ejército y líder de facto de Sudán y
muhammadán darlo conocido como hemetti
jefe de las fuerzas paramilitares de
apoyo rápido han hecho caso omiso de los
múltiples llamados de alto el fuego
desde su independencia del Reino Unido
su danza ha visto afectado por la
inestabilidad y los conflictos sigamos
con algunos datos sobre este país
sudada está situado en el noreste de
África su capital es jartum tiene
47,9 millones de habitantes y las
lenguas habladas son el árabe y el
inglés veamos ahora algunas fechas clave
de la historia del país
en 1956 Sudán se independizó del Reino
Unido entre 1955 y 1972 tuvo lugar la
Primera Guerra Civil entre el norte y el
sur el sur exigiendo más autonomía entre
1983 y 2005 sucedió la Segunda Guerra
Civil fue una continuación de la primera
y se cobró la vida de cerca de 2
millones de personas en 1989 el coronel
Omar lideró un golpe de estado y se
proclamó presidente entre 2003 y 2020
tuvo lugar la guerra de darfur donde el
gobierno de Alba a cabo una campaña de
limpieza étnica contra la población no
árabe de la zona según la ONU 300.000
personas murieron en 2011 Sudán del sur
obtiene su independencia en 2019 el
ejército expulsa del poder a Alba shir
tras meses de protestas populares contra
su régimen en 2020 el país firma un
acuerdo de paz para poner fin a la
guerra en la región de dar en el oeste
de Sudán y finalmente en 2023 los
militares y paramilitares que gobiernan
el país tras arrebatar el poder a los
civiles en un golpe de estado en 2021
terminan enfrentados lo que nos lleva a
la situación que vemos hoy y que
explicamos con detalle en el siguiente
informe
mientras dos poderosos clanes militares
rivales se disputan el poder en Sudán
los intensos combates ponen al país al
borde de la Guerra Civil
las tensiones entre el ejército sudanés
y los paramilitares de las fuerzas de
apoyo rápido llevaban meses latentes
pero fue en diciembre de 2022 tras el
establecimiento de un plan apoyado por
parte de la comunidad internacional para
una nueva transición de dos años hacia
un gobierno civil cuando la crisis entre
ambos bandos se intensificó dos puntos
exacerbaron la disputa las condiciones
para la inclusión de los paramilitares
en el ejército y el calendario de
transición
la revuelta Popular de 2019 suscitó
esperanzas de que Sudán pudiera salir
adelante tras décadas de autocracia
conflictos internos y aislamiento
económico bajo el mandato de Alba
Pero esto último conflicto no sólo ha
destruido esas esperanzas sino que ha
desestabilizado aún más una región
volátil situada entre el sahel el mar
rojo y el cuerno de África
después de la caída de albar las
potencias occidentales encabezadas por
Estados Unidos han tratado de impulsar
una transición hacia un gobierno civil
tras el golpe de 2021 cortaron la ayuda
financiera a Sudán para presionar a sus
autoridades militares los países del
Golfo también han intentado incluir en
los acontecimientos que se están
produciendo en el país además de sus
inversiones en diversos sectores Arabia
Saudita ha establecido estrechos
vínculos tanto con albertham como
cubremetti este último también ha
desarrollado relaciones con otras
potencias extranjeras como emiratos
árabes Unidos y Rusia Por último el
Egipto liderado por el líder militar
abdel fatal mantiene relaciones muy
estrechas con alburham de momento no se
ve el final de la crisis el ejército ha
clasificado a los paramilitares de mt
como fuerza Rebelde y ha pedido su
disolución Mientras que el señor de
guerra ha calificado a alburham de
criminal el ejército suranés dispone de
importantes recursos incluida una fuerza
aérea los paramilitares no se quedan
atrás y tienen unos 100.000 soldados
desplegados en jartum ciudades vecinas y
otras zonas lo que hace tener un
conflicto duradero que vendría a
agudizar una crisis económica y
humanitaria
cambiamos de tema en uganda hace un mes
los parlamentarios de este país de los
grandes lagos aprobaron un proyecto de
ley que impondría duras penas a los
homosexuales el presidente joely museo y
cuya firma es necesaria para que el
proyecto se convierta en ley decidió
devolverlo a los parlamentarios para que
lo modificaran no obstante en una
reunión en la capital campana reafirmó
su postura homófoba y acusó a occidente
de querer imponer la homosexualidad en
uganda el presidente está presionado por
la comunidad internacional incluidos
Estados Unidos y la ONU para que no
promulgue la ley cuando fue aprobada por
la asamblea nacional El documento
provocó una serie de condenas por las
organizaciones de derechos humanos y
parte de la comunidad internacional
pasamos ahora al cine Netflix y la
Organización de las Naciones Unidas para
la educación la ciencia y la cultura
quieren promover un nuevo cine africano
a través de un proyecto llamado cuentos
populares africanos reinventados la
plataforma estadounidense pretende
identificar a los cineastas más
prometedores de áfricano así seis
cineastas han recibido financiación para
crear y producir sus cortometrajes que
se estrenarán este año en Netflix
en cine africano de más acción y
espectáculo Esta es la apuesta de la
plataforma estadounidense en Netflix que
se ha Aliado con la UNESCO para
financiar seis cortometrajes de jóvenes
directores africanos
el cortometraje Encarna el emergente
cine de entretenimiento de África una
heroína se convierte en una implacable
justiciera persigue y acaba ahogando a
un soldado que causó la muerte de su
bebé la obra del director locumana
ilustra la de una nueva generación de
cineastas africanos más provocadora
frente a las tradicionales obras de sus
antecesores a menudo dedicadas a temas
serios
like es asombroso soy cineasta desde
hace unos años y parecía que no había
oportunidades para nosotros
especialmente
Así que es un cambio de ritmo muy
bienvenido
ejecutivo de Netflix África cree en una
edad de oro para el cine del continente
en la que la plataforma ayuda a crecer a
los cineastas africanos del mañana
reconocemos que estamos viviendo una
verdadera edad de oro para los cineastas
africanos de todo el continente
estamos encantados de formar parte de
ese movimiento las plataformas de
streaming son fundamentales en este
sentido gracias a sus recursos y a su
distribución compensan las Industrias
locales en las que pueden faltar
técnicos estudios y equipo pero para
muchos lo que el cine africano necesita
por encima de todo este reconocido por
el resto de la industria porque fuera de
las fronteras del continente los
directores africanos siguen sufriendo
los prejuicios la discriminación y el
racismo de los financiadores
[Música]
la autora nigeriana
estuvo en la capital colombiana Bogotá
con motivo de la Feria Internacional del
Libro en un poderoso discurso durante la
inauguración del evento la autora abordó
la cuestión de la identidad y nos
recordó que nuestro mundo está siempre
ligada al poder le preguntamos por el
vínculo entre identidad y poder en su
país Nigeria los dejamos con su
respuesta gracias por acompañarnos la
actualidad internacional continúa en
France 24 y 24.com
[Música]
Nigeria es multiétnica y multireligiosa
Pero tenemos casi una mitad de
musulmanes y una mitad de cristianos
creo que la religión es realmente una
línea de delimitación
y en términos de visibilidad ingenia
tiene constitucionalmente lo que
llamamos representación del carácter
Federal
Así que en los nombramientos las
políticas del gobierno establecen que
hay que tener en cuenta el carácter
Federal
lo que significa tener todo el mundo en
cuenta hay que tener a alguien del Norte
del Sur del este del Oeste hay personas
que han argumentado que quizá no sea tan
buena idea porque creen en la idea de
meritocracia
y dicen simplemente escogemos a la mejor
persona pero la razón por la que yo creo
en esta idea de representatividad es que
pienso que hay una buena persona en cada
grupo y que la capacidad no está
restringida a nadie
Si miramos Atentamente a cada grupo
siempre encontraremos a alguien muy
bueno para el puesto y es importante que
la gente se sienta incluida habría mucho
que pensar de la psicología de cómo
pensamos un liderazgo y deberíamos hacer
más si eres musulmán Es importante saber
que alguien que es musulmán como tú está
en una posición de poder te sientes
visible e incluido Así que Nigeria no lo
está haciendo perfectamente pero lo está
haciendo
[Música]